του φάση είναι στο μυάλλο της τελας κυριακήδου να υπάρχει μια πιο ενεργής ράσει γύρω
από το κόμμα κοιτάξετε είναι είναι οπολιτικός βου χώρος ημοόπως είπατε και σίσαντι πρόεδρος του
δυσία δέκα χρόνια όχο μια εξεριτική σχέσι με την πρόεδρο του του του κόμματος και
όταν επανέλθω πίσω θα είναι χώρος τον οποίο τα συνεχί σωνανίκο αποική και πέρα τα
υπόμενα βήματα θα τα δούμε επίσεις να σας πω κάτι το οποίο πολλές φορες παίνουμε
στο ότι είχει γίνει στην κύπρον και το θέμα του επιτρό που γιαμέένα ήσω το
πανε επιστήμειο πρικινο επίτροπος ήταν ι εκείνο βουλευτική συνέλευψη του συμτου συμβουλίου της ευρόπι στα
δέκα χρόνια θητίας σε εκείνοντο κοινοβουλίο που μου έδωσε ίσως και τα εφόδια ένα μπορώ
να ντα αποκριθώταν ήφθαν πανδημία με έναν τρόπο πιο διεθνί που πιστεύω ότι ήταν ένα
σημαντικό βήμα στην ενάρξη του πότα σ υπάότιστε μια κυρίά της πολιτικής που δεν έχει
κανείς να πει κάτι αρνητικό κακάτα ψέματα ο ποιο ρωτήσεις ι στενάτομο ευρίασαν μπορώ α
να μιλησουμε και πολτικούς ώρους ευρίας αποδοχής είναι στης σκέψεις της κυραστελας κυριακή του το
ενδεχόύμενο να κατέβει για πρόεδρος της δημοκρατίας πραγματικά στις σκέψεις τις τέλας κυριακή δου είναι
ένα λοκληρώσει τη θυτία της να επιστρέψει κύπρο να πάρει το χρόνο να κάνειτε σωστές
επιλογές και να αποφασίσω πως θα προχωρήσω δεν είναι κάτι που πραγματικά το έχω σκεφτικά
θόλου και για μέναν το ποιο θημαντικών είναι να να εσθάνουμε ότι εμαι ο φέλημι
και συνεχίζω να προσφέρω όπως έχω προσπαθήσει τουλάχιστο τόσα χρόνια στον τόπο μο ολλά και
τώρα εκτός κύπρου γι αυτό δεν είναι κ